hot breath if someone booking you
and it's going to be out of town ask for
a deposit
even even if you're a young comic like
our host
it doesn't it doesn't hurt the guy
offered you 500
can you send me 200 first i can't i
can't do the show
you're not losing 500 you never had you
never
you never had the 500 to begin with you
know what i mean yeah
so that was my thing from now on asking
for at least half
because if the show gets cancelled at
least i get money
and i learn lesson learn people i don't
give a
[ __ ] have you been doing comedy two
years once
somebody offers you money just say
they ask you how much you want to get
paid see that's a trick question from
that guy because
always ask for more than you want
say you only want to get paid 200 ask
the guy for 600
and work your way down to what you want
you're never
going to work your way up
hmm ever ever you ask for 500 he goes
all right here you go
oh can i get eight you're not gonna get
it you're not gonna get it
ask for the exaggerated amount always
especially you don't have an agent
just say oh man we can only pay you 500
okay does this
gig include a room is there going to be
a green room there it's going to be a
a hotel for us before we could stay at
well there's no hotel you could just
drive back all right can we have 700
then
because we're gonna need gas money we're
gonna need food
if you can't do none of those things for
you don't work with that guy you know
you're not going to lose no friend
you're going to you're going to be
better off
you're going to save yourself a big
headache what's the balance between
getting that stage time verse getting
the money
especially as you're developing as a
comedian well if nobody's offering you
any gigs
just keep doing stand-up comedy just
wherever whenever yeah
okay but if you want to make money and
stand up
i would say go to a restaurant or a bar
that has the hottest
friday saturday sunday like that place
is packed friday saturday sunday
i'm pretty sure it's whack on wednesdays
and it's
week on tuesdays so you tell the owner
listen man how do we do a
tuesday two for one college comedy night
ten dollars two for one and you tell the
owner um
i'll keep the door and i'll split the
door with you or whatever
whatever he agrees on and then you just
make a little bit of money
but always make sure that even if you're
a young comic
try to make fifty dollars at least for a
show it ain't a lot
but fifty dollars is gas bro it's gas
it's a meal
and you need it and you get ten shows
a month for fifty dollars five hundred
bucks
you know you gotta figure it like this
that's how i figured out my rent my rent
was
eight hundred dollars my phone bill was
a hundred
um my food was what
for the whole month for the whole month
with 102 i guess
so you figure i gotta make i gotta make
eleven hundred dollars a month all right
now for those young communists are
trying to book yourself for comedy shows
and you you need the money for next
month you can just forget about getting
booked for next month it ain't gonna
happen
it's not gonna happen right now we're
right now is july right was june june
29th
june 28th so july is already here
you could just forget about getting
booked for july trying to get booked for
november
see try to book your way ahead of time
so you don't have to worry about
december
if you could book december right now
with a bunch of shows
you're going to be good bro and then you
work you don't worry about december no
more now you worry about november
you get november filled up you got
october now you got august you got
september you get august
you got july but the rest of the fall is
booked
so july you find a job
you know august you open for somebody
whatever
but you try to book yourself like just a
guy that's booking a show for another
for
july oh where are we booked up okay man
how about
september see i'm pretty sure they asked
though they have september booked what
are what are some ways you recommend
getting booked
on these shows i would find out like
if there's a headliner coming into town
anybody smoke weed
show up and bring that for a fat sack
okay or or offer to drive him all week
be nice get in when you get when you
can't get in like
like that me like with a young cop
that comic really i should drive him bro
like he didn't he was an alcoholic so i
would just drive his car
i would go to his house park my car and
i would drive him around everywhere
try to be friends with somebody that's
making it you know somebody successful
or startup or um
start a podcast or the best way i would
say
is this like there's a comedy club like
bonkers or
or a punchline you find out um
who's booking the show and ask him man
hey bro
how about we have a bonkers podcast
what do you mean bonkers podcast well
you had like well when you get the
headliners that come in
maybe they could come in a day early and
we'll promote the show on my podcast
because people think that they think
too big like oh i'm never going to be
like joe rogan you're right
you're never going to be like george he
started his podcast
when podcasts first came out yep he's at
11 1500 episodes
forget about it but you could do is
be the hottest local club podcast
was when i was between a seven mile area
of your neighborhood
like if you could be the hottest podcast
in atlanta just in just in buckhead
think about it there's no other other
podcast in this town
you could be the only one and you saw
ads
to the local businesses yep now you
could walk up to a mall and paw
and offer mountain park listen mom and
paul i have um
100 500 subscribers within
five miles of your restaurant give me
200 a month and i will promote your show
every [ __ ] podcast
that's cheap advertisement bro
and i that's how we did it our first our
first
ad was uh was uh um la
la flor de la reina bakery
i told that guy give me 500 bucks and i
promote your podcast
for two months two months it's very
generous
yeah so we did it and we told people and
um he was our first guy and then
later on um we
we got p we had a we had a guest from
that show
um i'm dying up here on show time right
yeah for those that were promoting
people so they found out that we're a
comedy podcast
they paid us 1500 to interview him